今日は弾み冊です
今回
澄香さんの lovers という歌を
歌わせて頂きます
過去にボイトレとかしたんですけどももう
1年以上前で
全てのスキルを忘れてしまいました
なぜこの等
宇田をかと思ったかと言いますと結構恋人
の
曲なんですよねその
あの
浮気してもいいけど最後に僕を見てって
いう曲なんですけども恋人というか僕は
視聴者さんに向けてですと歌いたいなと
思っております
いろんなユーチューバーさんとかサイン
入りの雄2羽とどんどん出てきて
器がパスれる中で
やっぱり youtube を見始めた
きっかけがはじめしゃちょーでしたって
言われるんだよねー
最後に戻ってきてくれたなぁ
最後をはじめシャツを見たいな感じで
てくれたらいいなと思い日々とっ
感謝を込めて
痛いたいと思います
精一杯出してもらえます
[音楽]
涙の負けをペリしなくていい子の紙に
書き出してみたんだ
ni 削除いろいろ
自体の先に僕が付けていた
男ば最初になりカガリを
なはさに後に成田がるー
anaはやくっていわせねばどうやらとは
た下げなく復興者らしい
[音楽]
口約束結構号 c 中 ni 版はき s
ladder
したあああn
アヌ
dan
あのまま4
enni
ni
uhni
ああああああ
me
ni
nini
car
anohana
[音楽]
hamar
goo
me
uhn で耳悪されてボガー側に振り回さ
れて坊巫女の上の僕はムサケ脱いだ
[音楽]
ani から
クッキー柄
ニー
エラー
しee 2
d
8 ee
eee
ni
nini
when
ban
carcan you
坊
uh
me
ni
whme
dai
pandan
[音楽]
alana
goo
yeah
[音楽]
はい話がまったくからとかあるんですけど
もお皿です始めんとが当たった
ユーチューバーあるそむ別名動画作る人
あるあるソングが各カラオケのあの機種で
配信されておりまーす
はい皆のモバイルとかスイーツとかももち
どっちされるんですけども
今日からほとんどの家老系では多分歌える
と思いますねちょっと水はチェックして
ぜひ歌ってみてください
大人の事情でユーチューバーで僕は
ちょっと使い中谷だけの動画作る人という
ことでぜひ歌ってみてください
いいぞ家事一つでした
あと湯田様でした
ございましたーーー
[音楽]
voodooぱっちょ